[Musik]
bei diesem krieg geht es russland nicht
nur umland gewinne
als metaphysischen kampf so bezeichnete
das oberhaupt der russisch-orthodoxen
kirche anfang märz den angriffskrieg
am russischen osterfest gab kyrill putin
seinen segen
[Musik]
russland stehe kräften des bösen
gegenüber so hatte der patriarch zuvor
den krieg legitimiert
man möchte indem man apokalyptische
bilder entwirft deutlich machen um was
es eigentlich geht um eine
transzendieren nämlich diese
auseinandersetzung es geht um den großen
geistes kampf zwischen dem osten
der alle werte
sorgfältig bewahrt hat und dem westen
der den verfall der menschheit immer
weiter vorantreibt
anfang april rief carroll in der
hauptkirche der streitkräfte russlands
ganz in der nähe moskaus das militär
dazu auf ihr land so zu verteidigen wie
es nur russen können die kathedrale
eröffnet vor knapp zwei jahren symbol
der einheit zwischen russisch orthodoxer
kirche staat volk und militär mit
putin und kyrill an vorderster front
april hat insofern einen besonderen
bezug zum thema militär und verteidigung
als in seiner wahrnehmung russland ja
angegriffen wird und die russische welt
diese russische zivilisation von der
spricht dass die unter druck unter dem
druck des westens stäbler hat in einer
predigt gesagt dass der krieg vor acht
jahren begonnen habe und die idee
dahinter ist eben die ukraine hätten den
begonnen und jetzt komme die russische
armee den bedrohten in der ukraine zu
hilfe es ist die traditionslinie die die
orthodoxie immer verfolgt hat die
vorstellung ist dass man in symphonie
mit dem volk und mit der regierung lebt
und man hat keine andere aufgabe als die
in der führung dem volk zu arbeiten
der gleichklang von staat und religion
mit der taufe wladimirs des großen im
jahr 988 wird die russische orthodoxie
im mittelalterlichen reich der kiewer
rus zur staatsreligion das zarenreich
führt diese tradition fort erst die
oktoberrevolution 1917 bricht dann die
kirche gilt nun als konterrevolution er
priester werden mit heißem pech
übergossen kirchen zerstört oder als
wodka fabriken entwürdigt dann
marschiert die wehrmacht ein und trotz
der verfolgung der kirche ruft patriarch
sergius 1941 zur verteidigung des landes
auf die kirche finanziert aus eigenen
mitteln sogar eine panzerdivision
russland ist unser vaterland und das
müssen wir gegen eindringlinge von außen
verteidigen diese idee ist sehr wichtig
gewesen und das hat dann dazu geführt
dass die position der russischen kirche
sich nach dem krieg geändert hat sie
konnte existieren wenn auch in engen
grenzen es gab kaum noch diese blutige
verfolgung der preis den die kirche
dafür bezahlt hat war allerdings dass
sie eben die sowjetische politik
verteidigen musste nach dem krieg
kontrolliert stalin die kirche die
russische orthodoxie wird instrument
sowjetischer außenpolitik mitten im
kalten krieg propagieren russische
patriarchen im weltkirchenrat in genf
das bild der sowjetunion als
friedensmacht rechtfertigen blutige
einsätze der sowjetarmee als
friedenserhaltende maßnahmen
1975 wird der moskauer patriarch nikodem
präsident des weltkirchenrats
handschriftlichen abschriften aus kgb
archiven zufolge soll er als agent
gedient haben auch die patriarchen alexi
der zweite und der heutige patriarch
kyrill sollen demzufolge für den sowjet
geheimdienst gearbeitet haben
es gibt ja auch hier eine tradition dass
die obersten kirchenführer der
russischen orthodoxen kirche beim kgb
angebunden sind und dafür gibt es eine
reihe von
dokumenten und
es war zu sowjetzeiten
kaum möglich in dieser kirche karriere
zu machen ohne angebunden zu sein an den
kgb
mit der perestroika erhält die orthodoxe
kirche weitreichende freiheiten
gorbatschow braucht sie für seinen
reformkurs im april 1988 empfängt er
patriarchin im kreml die orthodoxie
tritt aus ihrem schatten dasein die
kirche fordert privilegien bittet sich
vom staat aus andere religionen klein zu
halten im gegenzug fühlte die
ideologische lehrstelle die der
sowjetkommunismus hinterlässt die kirche
hatte nach sind ideal sowjetkommunismus
die notwendigkeit sie zu erneuern auf
allen ebenen institutionell spirituell
personell und auf der ebene einer
institution deren erneuerung und auch in
der personellen dem personal muss
bezahlt werden war der stadt ein
wichtiger partner und diesen weg ist das
moskauer patriarchat gegangen hat
dadurch vielleicht auf zwänge geschaffen
die sie noch enger hinein gebracht haben
in eine enge verbindungen unterstützung
des staates
heute verbindet die kirche nationale mit
religiösen interessen die
präsidentschaft putins bezeichnete grill
als wunder gottes grill liefert
stichwörter für putins biopolitik der
begriff groß kenia stammt von ihm eine
russische welt die ansprüche auf gebiete
erhebt in denen die russische kultur
präsent ist mit dieser ideologie sind
die kriege der jüngsten vergangenheit
legitimiert worden
seitdem sich 2009 10 eine eigenständige
orthodoxe kirche in der ukraine gebildet
und vom moskauer patriarchat abgespalten
hat dringt kyrill darauf seinen
einflussbereich zurückzugewinnen
vor kurzem sprach er davon dass die
völker der heiligen russ vereint werden
müssten dies schließt auch die ukraine
eine großmacht fantasie die er mit putin
teilt
[Musik]
die beiden eigentlich eine einheit sein
und das ist in der in dem konzept des
kanonischen territoriums des moskauer
patriarchats ganz klar so formuliert
auf dem territorium der ukraine sollte
es eigentlich nur eine orthodoxe kirche
geben und die des moskauer patriarchats
diese visionen liegt auch dem handel von
patriarch kirill und seine unterstützung
des krieges zu grunde der russische
angriffskrieg bedroht auch die
vielfältigkeit orthodoxen lebens in der
ukraine
dass sich dort seit jahrzehnten
entwickelt hat
[Musik]
derzeit sagen sich immer mehr russisch
orthodoxe kirchen in der ukraine los vom
moskauer patriarchen so könnte kyrill am
ende durch seine hybris isolierter
dastehen als je zuvor